[Musique]
le fabricant de granola fourmis bionique
bien présent dans les épiceries du
québec se lance à l'assaut du marché
canadien et pour y arriver l'entreprise
de montréal a complètement revu son
image de marque tout en conservant son
nom francophone marie claude morin est
capable d'inverser geneviève gagnon a
beaucoup réfléchi au cours des derniers
mois tu as vraiment un gros processus
existentielle de questionnements
d'identité d'abandon de l'héritage de
certaines choses auxquelles j'étais très
attaché depuis les premières images les
premiers logos
après 18 ans en faire grandir ces
retours mais bionique elle s'est résigné
à laisser tomber le bionic pour percer à
l'extérieur du québec mais il était hors
de question de sacrifier sa fourmies à
voudra pas décemment dire quelque chose
mais les limites ou moins capable de le
prononcer donc ça va être beaucoup plus
facile puis on n'était pas prêt à
changer de nom prénom qu'ils allaient
plaît faites mieux vous voyagez sur les
marchés anglophones parce que notre
identité elle est québécoise on est
francophone que des valeurs culinaires
qui viennent avec ça puis une signature
gustatives
elle a aussi légèrement modifié le nom
de ses saveurs pour alléger les
emballages là l'idée c'était d'avoir un
nom au lieu de 10 20 pieds derrière ça
soit plus simple donc divine et
d'exprimer avec une illustration dans
quand même haut de gamme les ingrédients
puis l'essence du groupe
[Musique]
la fourmi est déjà présent dans 1700
points de vente au québec dont oui j'ai
à métro et provigo c'est granola sont
aussi vendus dans 300 épicerie en france
notamment chez monoprix l'entreprise
souhaite ajouter 500 points de vente à
l'extérieur du québec d'ici deux ans
surtout en ontario et dans l'ouest
canadien
l'équipe passera de 20 à 25 personnes
cette année et surtout un nouvel
équipement sera installé d'ici l'été
pour augmenter la productivité au niveau
de la production va s' est gardé ce côté
artisanal tout en ayant de la croissance
aujourd'hui on à automatiser la partie
emballages la partie vidage avec un
robot et donc la mat on veut optimiser
la partie mélange donc pour accélérer
davantage la croissance je vous dis tous
cas sur le plancher est toujours goûté
la céréale également pour ma tv que la
cuisson les adéquat l'entreprise réalise
actuellement une chiffre d'affaires de 4
millions par année
elle pourrait croître jusqu'à 10
millions dans ses installations
actuelles mais geneviève gagnon préfère
ne pas avoir d'objectif de chiffre
d'affaires s'est jamais au détriment de
la qualité alors à partir du moment
qu'une maîtrise procédé on y va l'autre
et dont on approche différente
l'opportunité puis y'a pas vraiment
d'urgence dans la croissance
contrairement à d'autres modèles
d'affaires dont on a toujours une
croissance organique
c'est comme ça qu'on veut envisager la
suite des choses
les nouveaux emballages feront
progressivement leur apparition sur les
tablettes à compter du mois d'avril à
mesure que les inventaires actuels
seront épuisés ici marie claude morin
radio canada montréal
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit